uh whether i had a cold or something at
the time i don't know
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today is a fantastic day because we have
some major confirmations for dr strange
in the multiverse of madness ever since
we got the super bowl trailer for
multiverse of madness and presumed that
we heard professor xavier's voice played
by patrick stewart we assume that the
illuminati are coming and the x-men are
also coming in multiverse of madness
[Music]
we should tell him the truth however
since it was not officially revealed to
be patrick stewart's professor xavier a
lot of rumors started to go kind of wild
and still a lot of people did not
believe that this person that we heard
is indeed patrick stewart's professor x
however today we can put that all to
rest as patrick stewart himself has come
out and seemingly confirmed that yes it
is indeed him he is returning as
professor xavier in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness and he even
talks a little bit about what it would
be like if professor x met dr strange
which could give us a little bit of
insight on how it's actually going to be
when the two of them finally meet in the
movie so a ton to break down in today's
video let's get started but of course if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu news now as most people know
by now patrick stewart has been going
around and he's been doing interviews
for his show picard captain jean-luc
picard from star trek the character he's
played since 1987. so he's been making
his rounds with the interviews and of
course everybody has to ask him about
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and today we finally get an
actual answer from him where he's not
trolling us the doctor strange trailer
can you comment on that at all
who's doctor strange
so in an interview with the youtube
channel jake's takes patrick stewart
confesses that this is indeed him in the
trailer and he describes his experience
that day in the following day take me
back to super bowl sunday a few weeks
back you're watching the game you're
trying to enjoy yourself everyone on the
planet's watching it and then a
commercial comes on for a marvel movie
in which someone kind of sounds like you
how quickly does your phone go off and
is there any part of you that thinks
i really just want to watch the game i i
i wasn't prepared for this well i had my
phone turned off as it happened and so i
didn't hear anything it wasn't until the
next morning
when i woke up and looked at my phone
and found that i had been bombarded with
responses and that my pr people had sent
me reactions that they had uh they had
detailed and passed on to me and um
i actually didn't recognize my own voice
it's it sounded different
whether i had a cold or something at the
time i don't know but i was astonished
and all they saw was the back of my
shoulder and i think my earlobe nothing
else that there would have been so many
connections made um but i it it uh it
treats me
now as you heard him say he says i
actually didn't recognize my own
voice he said it sounded different
whether he had a cold or something but
he didn't know but this right here is
him confirming that is indeed his voice
because he says he didn't recognize his
voice but then he goes further into the
confirmation that this is indeed him
returning as professor xavier he said he
was astonished that all people saw was
his shoulder and the back of his earlobe
again referring to that person in the
trailer as himself and he says that he
was astonished that people could make
the connection just by seeing that and
hearing his voice and he even says that
his pr people sent him a bunch of things
that he could say in response to if that
was him in the trailer in which it kind
of seems like now it doesn't really
matter whether this is patrick stewart
going off the books and kind of just
saying screw it i don't really care if
anybody knows anymore or whether it's
marvel studios saying hey it's pretty
obvious everybody pretty knows you can
come out at some point in time and admit
that yes that was you you are returning
as professor xavier which patrick
stewart sir patrick stewart is a top
tier actor and top tier person extremely
professional so i doubt he's saying all
of this without the approval of kevin
feige i'm guessing this is pretty
planned out and is probably planned in
the preparation of another trailer and
more tv spots coming relatively soon we
only have a few months till the actual
movie gets released so the promotion is
going to pick up very soon which makes
you think if they teased professor x in
the official trailer what more do they
have to come if they are confirming that
this is patrick stewart's professor x
right now let's talk about that in a bit
but patrick stewart does in this
interview also say what would happen if
professor xavier met doctor strange and
here's what he would have to say
what if
professor x met doctor strange what what
do you think would happen
professor x would be extraordinary
cautious
and watchful
and perhaps feel a little insecure
because there is something that is
potentially dangerous about this man and
i think that would i think that would
put uh
professor xavier on god
i love that so i actually think that
what he said right there could be pretty
revealing about the movie after all we
do see doctor strange in handcuffs in
the trailer and we do see him being
escorted to the illuminati by the iron
legion ultron bots this is actually kind
of a pretty big sign we don't really
know what doctor strange's actual crimes
are whether that's just messing with the
multiverse or another variant of doctor
strange has been going around causing a
lot of chaos we don't really know
exactly what has happened but most of us
assume that professor xavier is going to
be in charge of this multiversal
illuminati based off of the way he comes
into the room and says we should tell
him the truth it definitely seems like
he's in charge or he has somewhat of a
high status with the illuminati so it
looks like it could be at the call of
professor xavier to put doctor strange
in these handcuffs and have him be
escorted by the ultron bots and this
probably comes down to what patrick
stewart just said in this interview if
professor xavier ever met doctor strange
he would be incredibly cautious he said
that he would be cautious watchful and
maybe even a little insecure because
there is something that is potentially
dangerous about him now this potentially
dangerous part could mean that professor
xavier and the illuminati may not
actually know if our doctor strange is a
true threat to them other doctor
stranges may have been the scarlet witch
may be but they're unsure about our
doctor strange but they are still taking
caution by putting him in the handcuffs
and having these bots escort him we do
know however and unfortunately that
there will be a fight breaking out
quickly after doctor strange meets the
illuminati because the scarlet witch is
going to go to the illuminati
headquarters we know this because we see
the scene where doctor strange is being
escorted to the headquarters we see
statues of a winged person then we see a
fight between the scarlet witch and who
we believe now is captain marvel or king
but in this scene we see that same
statue so we know that the scarlet witch
is going to be fighting in the
illuminati's headquarters so a fight is
going to quickly be coming after the
only question is will the illuminati be
fighting doctor strange or will they
just be fighting the scarlet witch and
whose side will doctor strange take now
we've seen mordo fight him when he's
still in the handcuffs which means he's
most likely still at the illuminati
headquarters but will the illuminati be
smart enough to know that doctor strange
truly isn't trying to destroy the
multiverse or any universe he was simply
trying to save his own universe at
several points in time we'll have to
wait and see but patrick stewart has
confirmed he is returning as professor
xavier in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness for those of you
who may have had a little bit of doubt
you can put that to rest now because he
has admitted this himself so can not
wait for this movie it's going to be
absolutely fantastic a ton of cameos are
going to be appearing and professor x is
returning and he is a part of the
illuminati let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof